لعنه الفراعنه العالم الغامض عند قدماء
المصريين اهي حقيقه ام اسطوره
صوص كتبت على جدران المقابر لمنع اللصوص
يعتقد انها تسببت في احداث ماساويه
لمكتشفيها
وقصص عن عالم السحر وما يعرف بالعنه
الفراعنه دفنت مع اصحابها منذ الاف السنين
اثارت فضول العلماء انبهر بها الاعلام
وتناولتها السينما المصريه والعالميه
دفعنا الفضول للبحث في اصل هذه الحكايه
وحقيقتها فذهبنا لنمسك ببدايه الخيط مقبره
توت عنخ امون بوادي الملوك بمدينه الاقصر
[موسيقى]
اشهر تلك الاساطير كانت هنا مع فتح مقبره
توت عنخ امون القرن الماضي احداث غامضه
طالت افراد البعثه ما حير العالم لسنوات
طويله فلنكتشف حكايه هذه المقبره وسر هذا
اللغز
النور بيفطي واعلى وقام الكلب بتاعه في
نفس الوقت مات في قلعته في انجلترا طبعا
بص في الكلام هتلاقي سنه 22 الكهرباء في
مصر وطالع على طول نمره اتنين ازاي
في الوقت ده مات اتصلوا بلندن ده عشان
تطلبي لندن في الوقت ده ممكن تقعد اسبوع
او شهر على ما يردوا عليك
[موسيقى]
وفي السنوات القليله التاليه للكشف توفي
عدد من الذين كانت لهم علاقه مباشره او
غير مباشره بالمقبره ومنهم عالم مصريات
كان يعمل مع كارتر مات قبل انهاء عمله ما
عزز من الاعتقاد بوجودي لعنه حقيقيه ليه
حصلت
لان اللي هو ممول هذه المقبره ادى الحق
الحصري لنشر الاخبار عن هذا اكتشاف العظيم
لجرنان انجليزي واحد اللي هو التايمز
البريطانيه فده خلى كل الصحفيين التانيين
سواء من انجلترا او خارجها يفتعلوا قصص عن
لعنه الفراعنه وده اللي خلى هذا التيرم
وهذا المصطلح
يظهر منذ ذلك الحين
[موسيقى]
ومنذ ذلك الحين اطلقت عباره لعنه الفراعنه
على عده احداث غامضه وايضا اساطير ومنها
وجود مومياء على متن سفينه تايتنك قبل
غرقها في بدايه القرن الماضي واحد خبير
امريكاني غني جايب مومياء فكان هيجيبها
على الباخره فبدل ما يجيبها على الباخره
اداها هديه الى
المتحف فالميه لم مطرحتش على الباخره
اطلاقا
[موسيقى]
مقبره بيتي تقع بالقرب من اهرامات الجيزه
وهي احدى مقابر العمال بناه الاهرامات على
جدران هذه المقبره كتبت نصوص تحذيريه تحذر
كل من يعبث بالمقبره او صاحبها
[موسيقى]
المصري القديم لما كان بيسيب نصص اللعنه
على المقبره
على مقبره بيقول اسمعوا ايها الناس انني
لم افعل شيئا سيئا في حياتي وكل ما فعلته
كان صحيحا ولذلك احبتني الالهه وكل من
هيمص مقبرتي هتاكلوا التماسيح وفرس النهر
والاسود اعتقاد الفراعنه في البعث والخلود
وايمانهم الشديد بان المتوفى سيحيا من
جديد ليعيش حياه ابديه كان سببا في
استخدمهم للسحر ونصوص اللعنه وان كان معظم
علماء الاثار ينفون وجود تاثير لها
ما هي حقيقه لعب فرعون
لو قفلت الاوضه دي اللي احنا فيها 3000
سنه جوه هذه الحجره مومياء او بودع عضويه
بتطلع جراثيم غير مرئيه المومياء كلها
حاجات تتعفن بتطلع جراثيم علماء الاثار
زمان يقوموا داخلين بسرعه الجراثيم تقرصهم
يموتوا انا بعمل ايه دلوقتي بقوم فاتح
المقبره يوم او ساعتين او تلاته لما الهوا
الفاسق يطلع والهوى النقي يدخل وما فيش
حاجه اسمها
[موسيقى]
سمر بشات لصباح العربيه من القاهره